benvenuti solito story sulla vita ci
rifacciamo la challenge tre colori con
l'hiv challenge però abbiamo dei
nuovissimi colori e nuovi colori tipo
l'arancione non ce l'abbiamo mai avuta
alberto invece è preparato questa
tonalità
non abbiamo mai aiutata in più sono dei
colori perlati un po perlati un pò
metallizzati in portafoglio parlato sì
c'era scritto madreperla quindi siamo un
po per la tipo metallizzati che stiamo
super curiosi di vedere come e se lo
slime con questi colori nostro wow quale
colore vi piace di più fra questi
restano in viaggio per questo viola
percorre perché mi piace perché esso il
caso devo dire così diritto a casa per
cena al galaxy
a me quello che piace di tutto celeste
bellico lo so spero mi capiti questo era
scrivete voi nei commenti qual è il
vostro colore preferito marrone
allora perché ti capiti grigio grigio
telesto giardino
tra queste è dovuto tutto primo aperto
quindi sicuramente capiterà il verde il
cestino a te quindi questo è proprio
così uguali anche se non lo so rosso
rapporto allora voglio questo dovere
turchese aspetto forse ve ne siete
accorti ma questo sembra viola ma è
rosso da una bibbia che mai usato questo
tipo di rosso forse con una volta dei
colori a cera io che mi capiti corso
celeste se poi non so come sarebbe
mischiato questo non è certo per tutti e
se ti ho detto mi piacerebbe l'arancione
e il rosso rosa quando mese team misti
su centra così esce bene anche tu se
visti il via lei la trasparente sì con
le trasparenze così il colore si vedrà
ancora meglio e come stai regione perché
video dovrete votare se vinco io pioggia
a un milione di grosso
in base alla bellezza dello slider i
suoni smr quindi mi raccomando però che
il video fino alla fine che poi vi
metterò il sondaggio qua
mettetevi comodi
ora
ma chi inizia certo polemica sasso carta
forbice sasso piatto con un sasso dai
veneti cosa possa scendere il numero di
fare da una troviamo pianto la
canzoncina il gioco abbia volutamente
stampa noi canteremo una canzoncina ogni
volta bendata e voi dovrete indovinare
nei commenti che canzoncina è o da che
firme continua preparatore del testo
capito quale pure io vorrei che mi dove
e quale no me lo puoi dire ok fatto però
attenzione
sei sicuro ok ai team rosso si sa ciò
che sembra viola ma solo guardo meglio
su dj rosso a voi sembra viola un rosso
rosso che è in rosso ma non so perché
scarlato sembra viola fermi
nel caso è di colore
diciamo che formato pdf un bel marrone
ha portato già malissimo toccamenti dove
sarà una canzone che 900.000 brava qual
è la canzone che rimetta meglio perché
lo conosco di sbagliare il meno riaperto
un pochettino più
ecco sostegno in più vedere più piccola
setta satanica
questa festa dei diritti precisi e poi
si fanno mi sto mettendo tutti così lo
vedono meglio ha voluto mai scendere con
le celle sono da 1 a 5
allora
no quello no come lo è perché lo scherzo
quindi vuol dire che non è il bello se
no non avresti detto niente avrete
risultato quindi si apre celeste e violo
il mito ragazzi e vediamo come questo
rosso che stato preso e diamo pronti
prendiamo anni sembra dire il liquido
che strani così coloranti ma sono super
liquidi oppure pescato sistemazioni
mondo che strano sembrati con la lampada
lava avete presente la lava lamp la
lampada in cui c'è la lava che si muove
dentro amore ok io invece sono di un
colore mi piace in effetti già
bellissimo così oddio se ne voleva di
meno nel mezzo troppo
né sembra proprio il rosso ciliegia
perché ho tutte queste sfumature un po
metallizzate un po ferma per wow
by b ecco qua il mio viola ne metto meno
limitare queste no è troppo anche perché
il viola è un po scuro ma è bellissimo
l'effetto che fa sotto vedete è tutto
sceso sotto ha fatto un cerchio
che bello effetto tra un fiore mi
ricorda lo so sembra strano che sembra
in fiore però mi ricorda un fiore e
bellissimo proprio il metallizzato un pò
di sfumature di viola più scuro wow è
stupendo mi piace tantissimo l'effetto
non vedo l'ora di attivarlo è vedere
come diventerà sperando che eventi un
brutto colore è mischiato con gli altri
modi burberi e bellissime veramente già
un galaxy cioè basta un po di questo
colore per fare un galaxy qualche i
glitter magari anche questo ragazzo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mai fatto
indovinate che funzionerà non voglio
rovinare bio bio aggravarsi bellissimo
non ho sentito nessun rumore da parte
che vuole dire che qualcosa di bello
aspettiamo solo che è cambiato casa la
maledizione del berti deve fare bene da
via per renderlo noto sono forse non sa
che cosa tanta l'uso del bagno bunker è
stato zitto e quello che vedo come
quanto ci posso fare io si tratta si
ragazzi di carta ok fatto pesca pensaci
bene questo certo
[Musica]
manovra che ci starà benissimo nel tuo
dimettermi non ha idea di come diventerà
viola converte vediamo grigio trading
non è tutto perché perché sono esperto
che ballo con tutto così sfumature
perlate non ti preoccupare adesso verrà
provinato del garda nella deve rovinare
allora perché colori si devono agitare
un po perché sono super liquidi e strane
che sono super caldi allora si dovrà
girare girare girare abbastanza ma come
berlino il viaggio da oggi ottantenne
tele giornata di oggi anche messo un bel
po e si aspetta
l'effetto caso proprio libro bellissimo
così magari rimanesse così ma non vede
no adesso chi rischia l'effetto dei tuoi
colori ma cosa sta uscendo grigio
no secondo me se marroncino perché sta
diventando tutto verde sembra che sta
diventando un euro uguale ma sta
diventando tutto verde ma come no dai
non è possibile
no no forse parlando sta tornando il via
la sta tornando la stava scalando che
agrigento non si fida colore a tesi così
un grigio perlato bello con le sfumature
violetto il grigio palanzana anzi la
melanzana ero sembra un po melanzana dai
pensavo peggio non è male
pensavo peggio valore di anche bene
è bello vediamo di strano sembra proprio
metallo liquido è bellissimo
vediamo ora il tuo come diventa allora è
doveroso per rosa tyrian nacré cosa ti
rihanna crei e tyrian e tirannico d'aria
devo agitare una madre
eccolo qua quasi non si vede perché è
talmente forte il rosso vediamo giocate
che bell effetto un altro perché si
stanno benissimo questi due colori anni
color fragola si è cambiato infatti più
perché dolce con come tonalità che bello
e molto acceso quindi stupire giù fino
alla quale vi piace di più è quello per
facilitare o il miglio metallizzato un
po oscuro però purtroppo è diventato
nero nero tu lo volevi celeste invece
che cammina trovarmi bene cosa deciderà
il destino del nostro tra il man city
tutto quale vuoi che ti capiti amico lo
dico allora secondo me doveva duo ci
starebbe bene l'arancione a cappotto
rosso così va bene robben rullino il
turchese
invece questo celeste su questa vostra
soffermerebbe io sì marrone può essere
invece questa celeste qua forse potrebbe
chiarirlo un po renderlo un pochino
rovina oppure quello guardone vera buio
il petrolio attraverso la canzone penso
che lo rovinerebbe un bel po
diventerebbe smarrimento e marrone sola
ragione quindi tu la ragione io voglio
celeste vediamo chi inizia caretta
fornita so chi sei pronta si va
rischiano di vista mi aspetto che per la
canzone e bravate bene
[Musica]
siri mischia ok sta mischiando fatto
fatto perché mi attirava per fortuna per
la celeste quindi forse diventerà un po
più cari quindi io non vedo perchè trovo
questo si baciano regione intanto
proprio fortunato questa volta che è
fortunato a lavorare quando esce
grigetto marrone rosa scaduto da bergamo
per favoriti
ok vediamo mentre tutti gli ultimi
colori vediamo consenta ecco qua il mio
celesti turquoise i bellissimi ma è
bellissimo il signore o fate punto del
video che sono rovinati o se sono così
vediamo che si mischia bellissimo però
ho paura che non si vedrà molto vediamo
cappello e stupendo vorrei tirare la
giudicò non ti piace e bellissimo sta
schiarendo forse diventa un grigio
metallizzato come le macchine
e diventato veramente un grigio
metallizzato con qualche riflesso
celeste e verde non mi piace però non è
male più bel colore macchina e 4 tutto
mischiando e al mio arancione si chiama
orange mercato vediamo
apriamo horizon ha creato tantissimo
cucina pallone amministrata
speriamo che bello questa ragione colore
particolare guarda sembra un fucsia
chiaro ma sto molto simile a gestire le
sfumature però rimasti su ciliegia lo
stesso un po del tuo team scelte
bellissimo anche questo
sono proprio curioso di vederli attivi
con quello più bello il mio paletti
bello il mio era una domanda che abbiamo
rischiato i nostri tre colori ora non ci
resta che attivarlo e puoi farmi vedere
bene così potrete votare più bella per
bellezze sony smr sembrati 3 2 1
ecco allora il colore come potete vedere
una sorta di grigio metallizzato e allo
studio di grigio metallizzato però mi
piace molto perché mi ricordo appunto
crisi come tale stato delle macchine un
po violetto tende un po al violetto e
allora il rimane molto metallizzato
vedete molto lucido realizzato mi piace
un sacco questo effetto
poi ovviamente ora lo sta in trasparente
deve ancora schiarirsi completamente
quindi è ancora poco poco opaco però una
volta che tutte le bolle bollicine vanno
di escherich è completamente sarà ancora
più lucido metallizzato quindi ancora
più bello
quindi mi piace tantissimo questo
effetto
ora sentiamo un po di studi smr vediamo
[Musica]
il sogno allora scrivete pure cosa ne
pensate di questo che vostro girate da 1
a 10 e questo per metallizzato vediamo
ora quelle di vitale e vediamo quali di
ghiacci di pirati a vedere uno slide
bellissimo sembra un sorbetto alla
ciliegia brandolino il colore è
bellissima mi sembra un po meno
metallizzato come colore però è un
colore bellissimi stupendo guardate è
proprio un sorbetto gelato non voglio
influenzare ma votate l'italia potrebbe
mettiamo i suoni e che a suoni
[Musica]
ma il colore metallizzato attenzione
volevo solo falato
volevo solo far notare che stranamente
lo attivato questa sì bene non troppo
che di non vale
non male vogliamo sempre di più milione
vediamoli uno a fianco all'altro
[Musica]
wow sorta più belli così tutti
bellissimi quelli privatizzati quale vi
piace di più è caduto avete votato nel
sondaggio finto evitare l'addio
all'europa volgarotto bolla quindi
portate chi vince lasciato un bel live
per altre challenge tra i manifesti
sapere nei commenti che altre challenger
volete vedere e ora cliccate su una di
queste quattro castellini per vedere i
nostri prossimi video cliccate su quella
che preferite